mais
wendy gagnant donc moi je concours dans
la catégorie
j'avais mis création d'emplois mais je
crois que c'est pas la bonne catégorie
donc je suis plutôt dans l'insertion en
fait je suis maquilleuse donc depuis un
an et demi donc je travaille pour un
gros groupe de parfumerie en mettant
prestataires de services donc en fait le
maquillage dans tout le monde connaît
mais souvent c'est assimilé à
l'esthétique donc je suis pas
esthéticienne je suis vraiment
spécialisé dans le maquillage c'est pour
sublimer en fait les beautés
réunionnaise de n'importe quel type donc
ça peut être un homme une femme j'ai
déjà maquillé des hommes des femmes
voilà ça peut être dans le mode la
beauté ça peut être pour une pub ça peut
être pour un mariage ça peut être donc
tout on va dire toutes sortes de
prestations qui peut exister où on a
besoin d'être maquillée derrière voilà
ça peut aider une personne à se voit là
à se sentir mieux dans sa peau ça peut
aider des personnes à camoufler des
petits des petits défauts et moi je suis
là voilà pour les maquilleuses
itinérante donc je fais toute l'île
voilà après j'aime mon métier j'aime
tout ce qui touche à la création donc on
voit on voit pas tous les jours les
mêmes mille visages on va pas tous les
jours les mêmes gens donc moi c'est ce
que j'aime dans mon métier et j'avais
envie de faire partager ça en fait il
faut dire que je suis pas du tout ici de
ce milieu là à la base moi j'ai un dss
de communication option journalisme
il n'y a pas du tout lien avec
l'esthétique j'ai eu l'opportunité en
fait de rencontrer le grand patron d'une
parfumerie est en fait il m'a débauche
et il m'a dit voilà est-ce que vous les
êtres notre maquillage officielle
pour ce groupe là j'ai dit oui alors
sachant que vois je voulais pas être
employé je voulais vraiment être à mon
compte et du coup il a accepté mes
conditions et à côté je peux faire quand
même d'autres choses dot je suis pas que
lié à ce groupe là je suis vraiment pour
moi et c'est ce qui me plaît d'être
libre en fête voilà